you're persistent i love that because
you've been trying to get me on this
podcast for a long time
and until i saw you on another podcast
and you said you were russian did i call
you back
then it was over because russia to me
you know is leading the world in
wrestling
almost every year what's the difference
between american wrestling and russian
wrestling you showed me this painting
well it's mit it's science it's science
you know
and they they really study the sport
they're really good
technically they're really really good
in strategy
they don't really push like the real
toughness they don't push
like uh conditioning right and so
americans we need what they have
russians need what we have
and if when the when you get to two
together and for me
why i could beat the russians is because
i went their way a little bit but i i
kept my toughness
but you're known you're you're known for
your toughness
yeah but i wasn't known for my art i
wasn't known for my science
so when did you become a bit of an
artist it took a loss
delirious an artist just because i won
181 straight
dominance in seven years and not just
winning but you know kind of
punishing people yes and from from that
point of view yeah it might have been
pretty good but i had a long ways to go
yet
and i didn't really realize that or i
should have
i should say i didn't really know how to
get it out of me until i had a loss
and then i realized i gotta buckle down
learn some of that science
become more of an artist how do you
become an artist so
that the russian way has this
drilling technique thousands of reps
how do how do you think you work on the
science the art part
you gotta study the best in the world
uh i think dave schultz was our guy in
america
that probably showed us that
being artistic you needed that and he
studied it he went over there as a high
schooler
and wrestled in some major tournaments
over there and he
saw their ways he used that russian
science and then he
was already an american and he saw what
how i trained athletes he saw what i did
in the olympics
saw what other people how he held up and
he applied that as well
but i'd have to say he was more the
artistic type he was more of a russian
than an american when it came to uh uh
wrestling
you